I know we were talking about photography
yesterday today we've got a young man in
the studio he's Adam Jacobs and he's
been lucky enough to to photograph lots
of very very famous people and events
from Nelson Mandela to the Olympics
World Cup football all sorts of things
but even leaving his room for Adam was
impossible only a few years ago and he's
here to tell us why and how photography
has been an absolute lifeline for him
what what is your illness and so I
suffer with a illness called Potts
postural orthostatic tachycardia
syndrome
along with chronic daily migraine and
which is precisely really what it sounds
like on the tin and having a migraine
which is a lot more than a headache 24/7
suffering with sensitivity to light and
sound even to touch and and have been
suffering that with that for almost 12
years now and got into photography and
through actually having this illness I
originally was going to be a banker and
work in the city and but ended up
through quite a long story and was going
to start my university degree at
Nottingham and became unwell had one
migraine which morphed a two to three
eight and eventually I had one of these
migraines 24/7 left me laying in a dark
for almost two years completely
debilitated and unable to watch
television look at a computer even eat a
meal with my family because the sound of
cutlery clinking sounded to me like a
steam train going past and and I was
fortunate enough that unfortunately
actually after two and a half years of
not being able to really make any
progress I went to America for treatment
and and while there I was in a expert
centre for head pain chronic head pain
and and when I came out of the hospital
and I started doing very small menial
tasks that to you guys would seem like
nothing going to a coffee for five
minutes going to the grocery store for
five minutes
but at a time like me was climbing
Everest and I was in a place called Ann
Arbor a small collegiate town but what's
there is America's largest stadium 113
thousand people for collegiate sport
just watch when you're Telus I continue
that story of just getting our director
to run the photographs that you're that
you're known for that you've taken but
yes please contain the service
photograph I was one of my tasks that I
went when I first come out of the
hospital and and this is the Michigan
Stadium and as I said collegiate sport I
went in took this photograph and I went
to take it into a photo store to be
developed and the lady came out and I
was studying economics at the University
of Nottingham never really considered a
career in photography and and when I
went to went to pick it up and she came
out and said I hope you don't mind me
asking but are you a professional
photographer and I looked at her like
she was now you thought no but good idea
could be exactly these are some of the
amazing people that you have been able
to photograph
since yes and I mean it really has been
a remarkable journey through getting so
unwell my life completely threw a
spanner in the works of my life took my
life in a completely u-turn direction
how did you get these people suppose for
you because I know Andy Murray and I I
don't think photography sees favorite
thing you know yeah I mean part of my
job is obviously getting people to relax
and it's being a people person that's a
big part of being a photographer not
only working with light and
understanding the technicalities of it
but also getting such luminaries and
well-known people as Andy Murray and I
was fortunate enough to be in an office
with being Nelson Mandela's office with
just himself and President Clinton and
but it's getting these people whether
they're very well-known celebrities or
my photograph done stories on the
homeless or whoever it may be is making
these people feel comfortable and making
them feel like you're up there they're
your friend and well that's Adam with
that view of so Jamie's bedroom
it's no problem at all but it's actually
what's interesting is is is I find for
me that the photography has been almost
therapeutic of course and and this
series that I've done what you see that
photograph behind me and is actually
used to be America's largest car plant
and is now completely abandoned and I've
done as soon as I find the photography
quite meditative and quite therapeutic
and this abandoned space is series which
I've released a limited number of series
of which are available on my website and
which is out on Jake's photography comm
with proceeds going towards the migraine
trust and the autonomic charitable trail
good luck to you Anglia continued
recovery from all of this and and what
you're trying to do in such enjoyable
photography born out of such a bad thing
thank you thank you that's Adam Jacobs
and he's the man with a camera the woman
with the weather Joe wheeler